Aiden Gomez is a computer scientist and
widely recognized AI expert who
co-founded AI company cohere before that
he worked as an intern in the Google
brain team in Toronto alongside Jeffrey
Hinton one of the Godfathers of deep
learning actually the only Godfather who
hasn't been on mlst Aiden you need to
put a good word in for us
I will I will I'll bring it up so Gomez
was the kind of person Hinton record who
had so many ideas it was difficult to
pin him down and to get him to focus on
what he was actually supposed to be
doing now Gomez was particularly
interested in learning to translate
languages and while he was at it he
casually invented Transformers which as
we all know have become the de facto
basic like reference architecture for
all neural networks and not only for
language tasks now cohere is a startup
which uses artificial intelligence to
help users build the next generation of
language-based applications it's
headquartered in Toronto and the company
has raised 175 million dollars in
funding so far and the first round was
from index Ventures and the round also
included Hinton who we just spoke about
feifei Lee and Peter abil who are very
very famous folks in the ml space
now coheres say that their competitive
advantage or at least at least one of
their competitive advantages lies in its
focus on safety which is crucial for
customers deploying models which could
potentially output something harmful and
we'll discuss what we mean by that a bit
later on now I can honestly say
personally that language models have
transformed how I use computers over the
last six months or so I've been using
them on a daily basis in the form of
scripts which helped me use the command
line better using an interval an
interactive reple playground for doing
all sorts of stuff like composing emails
for me understanding error logs when I'm
coding summarizing information
performing repetitive tasks you name it
actually I regularly discover new tasks
that I can use for language models just
through kind of creative exploration so
I'm a bit of a convert although um
caveat mtor is still definitely in
effect the words of Chomsky Fodor and
volition are still ringing loudly in my
ears we just did some content about that
in our last show but anyway Aiden it's
an absolute honor welcome to mlst and
what's it like being the CEO of one of
the fastest growing startups
uh thank you so much for having me I'm
stoked to get to meet you and chat about
kohir
um what's it like being the CEO of coher
it's
a privilege and uh
a thrilling ride like uh you're just
hanging on for dear life as things are
going and and trying to keep up
um but it's honestly just such a
privilege like to get to work with the
people that I work with on the problem
that we work on I uh
I think I'm just so so lucky and
fortunate I'm really really excited to
get into the discussion about um
Transformers and attention is all you
need so
um I mean I remember when this came out
in about 2017 actually it changed the
landscape of deep learning forever it
took me um a very long time to
understand it and I probably only did
understand it after reading Jay's famous
blog post you know the illustrator
Transformer Jay of course is he your
engineering director now
yeah yeah so Jay is uh
the best Communicator in machine
learning that I know he's incredible
um and I think if you search
I think if you search Transformer neural
net on Google it's not our paper that
comes up it's Jay's blog so it tells you
like how much better his communication
is than ours I thought it was an epic
blog he's actually done a new blog post
on um stable uh diffusion as well and
folks should also subscribe to his
YouTube channel he's got an amazing
YouTube channel but
um but but anyway it was Jay's blog post
and yannick's video that made me finally
understand it because at the time it was
the the most exciting
um kind of technology and I remember I
was interviewing for the Bing team at
the time and I spent a long time
studying the paper just so that I could
be conversing in it when I had that
interview but anyway um can you tell us
you know what was the story behind the
paper and also what's special about
Transformers
yeah so the story behind the paper
um
I should say that like I was the intern
on this project and so I was the baby
like doe eyed showed up in Google brain
down in in Mountain View
um
and my contribution was really on the
software
so there were existing threads inside of
Google brain
primarily driven by
uh Noam Shazier
um yakubuskarite
lukash Ashish which we're we're pushing
along this idea of deploying these Auto
regressive sequence models for text
because they had been really popularized
in wavenet for audio and language
Generation
Um
but there was like a big push towards
how do we deploy these against text and
how do we incorporate attention which
was something that was groundbreaking
for rnns like the previous generation of
model they wanted to incorporate this
into these new auto aggressive sequence
models
and so when I came in I was working with
lukash focused on like the software side
of things scalable training Frameworks
um supporting training that
you know could be distributed across not
just tens of machines or hundreds but
thousands of of accelerators
um
and so we built tensor to tensor which
was the framework that was used to
develop the Transformer
um
shortly after we started putting that
together I was sitting next to Noam
Shazier
um
and we heard that he was also kind of
thinking along similar threads for these
Auto aggressive models and so lukash and
I convinced him to come over to tensor
to tensor and start doing it on our
framework and then we heard over in the
translate department so brain was one
division of Google translate was a
separate one over in translate there was
yakabashish Nikki working on a similar
project to gnome where they wanted to
create a
purely attentive model stripped back all
the complexity of rnns all of these like
very complex Gates and states and Etc
and just just rip that all away and just
have
MLPs and attention layers
um
and so we all came together we all
Consolidated on this framework called
tensor to tensor in the next three
months up until the nurbs deadline was
just a Sprint like um sleeping in the
office
just going as fast as you can running
experiment and iteration and iteration
and finding this bug and that bug
um
and so really like a huge piece of the
project came together within 12 weeks
um
so it was like
an extraordinary pace
um and it was as an intern this was like
my first experience in like proper
proper research and I just thought this
was normal I thought okay this is what
everyone does we all just crank out
papers in three months we sleep at the
office
um
and I I didn't really have an
appreciation for what we had
accomplished at the end like I can't say
that I was particularly prescient at the
time I remember like the night before
the nurbs deadline the night before we
had to submit
um
it was like whatever 3 A.M
uh Ashish and I were sitting on a couch
in the brain office
and he turned to me
and he he said you know like Aiden like
this is going to be huge
and my reaction was like
we bumped up blue like the blue score by
one point I was like really you think so
oh cool like don't we all like isn't
this what research is we just bumped it
up a point what's the big deal but I
think what I didn't appreciate was
um
the fact that such a simple method
could achieve such insanely high
performance
like at that time we were training on
eight accelerators for one of these
models and they could be trained in
within a day
um
but the architecture was so stripped
down it was so refined it was so easy to
scale and to grow I just
it was hard to see the future
um and it was hard to see what would
happen which was this massive scaling
project and I think Ashish saw that
that happening
um
so yeah that was my contribution that
was the part of the team that I uh I
brought
um
but yeah it was a very very exciting few
months and then it was an extremely
exciting few years afterwards before I
left Google and and started cohere I can
imagine and as you say some of the best
work happens in Sprints and even though
it only moved the needle a tiny bit on
the blur score something we'll explore
later is sometimes it might actually be
performing better than the metric might
might suggest and and simple models are
often better but I wanted to ask a bit
of a technical question so um deepmind
recently released a paper called neural
networks and the Chomsky hierarchy
they grouped a bunch of tasks according
to the formal language classes in the
Chomsky hierarchy and they showed that
Transformers were only able to represent
finite languages so not not even regular
languages which rnns could do neural
networks could only support the higher
modes like context-free languages if
they were memory augmented with a stack
and they said that this had implication
for scaling laws
um so for example the Transformers
architecture they said could never
perfectly learn tasks which were higher
up in in the hierarchy so we've done
some shows on mlsd where we've spoken
about neural networks not being too
incomplete because they are finite State
automators without the augmented memory
so for example they couldn't approximate
pi to the nth digit and there's this
photo and volition connectionism
critique paper which we spoke about on
the last show and that basically means
that neural networks are not able to
perform symbolic compositional reasoning
or in plain English they can't represent
infinite objects and we spoke to Randall
bellistrio and he had this paper called
the spline theory of neural networks
which showed that a neural network is a
linear operation given a single input
example so given all of this I
personally find the conversation about
scaling laws I'm a bit skeptical about
it although I'm genuinely interested in
emergent Properties or transients that
happen during the scaling process but
given all of this I mean how do you
think about the Practical limitations of
Transformers in terms of what algorithms
they can learn
yeah like I really hope that
Transformers aren't the last
architecture
um
like I I would be extremely disappointed
if this is as creative and high
performing as we can get I think that
Transformers took off because of their
scaling properties and also because of a
network effect the community
Consolidated around this one
architecture we started to build all of
this infrastructure specifically for
Transformers there was a network effect
and it had very nice scaling properties
and so the community really came
together around this architecture and
built up infrastructure to support its
adoption
um I think that's what's led to their
proliferation or their success
um
I hope that it's not the last
architecture that would be super super
disappointing and
boring
um you point out that
they're not turning complete I I should
like clarify that I'm not a linguist I'm
not too familiar with Chomsky
hierarchies or the implications of the
deep mine paper but
um one thing that's interesting about it
when I read it
they're not speaking in theoretical
terms or speaking in empirical terms of
what functions are achievable
um
from a you know normal initialization
um
and so I think that's a fascinating lens
like in theory a Transformer is a
universal proximator and it might be
even turn complete
um but in practice
if you can't explore all permutations of
parameters
um it's very true that it'll it'll find
the simplest function that satisfies the
task
um
I think that's like a good guiding lens
when thinking about what architectures
come next where do we go from here
what are the sorts of components we need
to add into neural networks to support
them in representing these more complex
these more complex functions
um
so I do think that Transformers are
limited and I really hope they're not
you know our final architecture I hope
that we come up with something that's
significantly better and I see
promising efforts along those directions
I think that retro from deepmind like
augmenting Transformers with a
searchable memory I think that's a huge
step forward
the next thing we need to support is the
ability for these Transformers to keep
State over long time Horizons to be able
to write into their own memory in order
to you know make notes about what
they've seen in the past
um
and so I think there's a lot of work to
be done and it's not happening fast
enough I think more people should pick
up these research questions and look for
new scalable ways of doing it because
like to speak to
the scaling hypothesis
like the real bottleneck for feature
adoption the real bottleneck for adding
in a new component to the Transformer
architecture
um
it's all scale and efficiency
people will just adopt the thing that is
simplest fastest and best performing
and so we need to do the work in order
to make these other components like
addressable memory
um
efficient and scalable in the same way
that the core vanilla Transformer
architecture is today
yeah it's such a paradox isn't it
because the Deep the deepmind paper was
saying that a turing machine is the most
powerful computational model but neural
networks are trainable and they scale
really really well so I'm sure we'll
find some Innovation that that will
somehow bridge that Gap somehow but I
wanted to learn a little bit more about
coher so could you tell us about your
core product portfolio and what's on
your roadmap
yeah for sure so um the mission with
cohero is to really just give technology
language and the way that we want to do
that is put the tech put these large
language models into more hands today
um
if you're building a product and you
want to deploy a language model as part
of that you've got to learn how to use
uh you know some framework like pytorch
or jacks or tensorflow you need to learn
how to install Cuda kernels on a VM
which is actually a huge huge task
um and so it's this very painful process
requires a lot of learning it's very
unnatural and
um
requires a ton of prerequisite knowledge
so for cohere what we want to do is
abstract that away we want to present an
interface which is just intuitive
natural like cohere.classify you feed in
um the tweet that you want to classify
you give some examples tweets being
classified into the categories that you
care about and then you get a response
which says yeah that tweet fits into
sports or whatever
um
so we want to create a portfolio of
these endpoints which just makes this
technology more accessible and the goal
being that it starts to proliferate
um
because I I think the Transformer was
released half a decade ago
and I saw extraordinary research level
um
results or contributions
from it right like the ability to write
really compelling tags the ability to
few shop prompt and get pretty good
performance on a huge swath of problems
but it just hasn't been changing the
fabric of consumer applications and I'm
a consumer you're a consumer we all use
these apps and so as a researcher who's
seeing the potential of the technology
it's super frustrating you just wonder
like what what is the
what's stopping this from getting out
there into apps faster and I I think
like two of the reasons are there's this
huge compute barrier right like to train
these big models you need a super
computer and
tons of data that's very difficult to
to use and collect
um
so so the compute is definitely one of
the big barriers but the second piece is
that
really it's like the people right like
at the moment yeah we have millions of
developers on our planet
but a tiny tiny tiny tiny fraction of
them actually know how to do this
specific thing machine learning and
training models and so there's not a lot
of people out there actually doing the
work to integrate this into every
product on Earth
and so for us like I cohere what we want
to do is just
blow that open
put this stuff into the hands of every
single developer doesn't matter what
your specialty is if you're a database
Dev if you're mobile tele whatever you
do it doesn't matter
the important thing is that now you can
build with large language models because
you're given an interface which doesn't
require
you know three years of study to get up
to speed
so that's really what we're what we're
pushing for it's quite ironic actually
because I was involved in ml devops for
many years and normally introducing
machine learning into software
engineering makes it exponentially
harder that now we seem to have jumped
to language models where it's become
easier again and I want to talk about
the language being a new type of
interface for software but we'll save
that just for just for a minute
um I want to talk about the friction
using large language models as a startup
owner so I'm a startup founder myself
and I want to use large language models
because I'm very excited about them and
um
you know I can speak to some of the
friction that I've been experiencing
looking into this so um I mean if we
look at what's happening over at open AI
for example the the Microsoft sign up
form and the content policy over there
is quite intimidating they've made it
quite challenging to use in production
and um actually it makes me wonder how
many people are using it in production
they say that content creation
applications have a higher chance of
misuse which seems like an oxymoron to
me because gpt3 is literally like a
content creator
um they say you're going to expect a
call from the Microsoft vetting service
they can pull the rug from under you at
any time for any reason they log and
record everything under the guise of
safety they can't be held liable for
anything as I said open-ended
applications are refused and in my
opinion the most exciting applications
are the open-ended applications right I
love the playful nature of it inside my
application I want to build a community
of tinkerers who discover interesting
new sub applications right I want to
build a Marketplace of prefab prompt
structures on top of my platform on I
don't want to specify exactly how my
application will be used right you know
I want I want my application to be fluid
and large language models make the
consumers of an application kind of like
programmers of that platform themselves
I think it's an entirely new paradigm so
with that in mind and the friction
um do you think that would ever be
allowed on coher for the startup that
you're describing well this idea that I
shouldn't need to say to cohere exactly
how I'm going to be using the platform I
want it to be very open-ended and
playful I want my users to create new
prompts and share the prompts and use it
in interesting ways I want it to be as
open-ended as possible yeah I think onco
here that would be fine
subject to your users complying with
some basic ethical principles so
presumably like I imagine that you don't
want your users creating
Bots which propagate false information
or hate speech on on Twitter you don't
want like a a billion bot accounts
responding to every every article
um and so I assume that you're also
incentivized to have some degree of
terms of use is that is that right
yes I I completely agree with your terms
of use I think it's very good actually
um the the one sticking point for me is
that in order to have my application
vetted I have to say how it's being used
and it seems to be slightly away from
having just quite an open-ended
application but I absolutely agree with
all of the points in your content policy
okay yeah so I think that startup should
absolutely exist that sounds awesome
like a community of people sharing
prompts iterating with each other
figuring out stuff that works doesn't
work I think we saw a lot of that with
mid-journey and stable diffusion right
like just this
Collective effort to like let's figure
this thing out let's discover new new
ways to use it that should 100 exist in
the world and cohere with 100 support
that
um I think at the same time
um there are just application domains
that we don't want people building uh
like you know uh the ones that I just
described
um
so as long as you're okay
filtering those out and working with us
to make sure that your product doesn't
get used in those ways
um
we're fully on board like that should
exist that sounds amazing and I think
like more broadly
coherence stance is
we really want to see a proliferation of
this technology we want to see a million
new startups born from it and so we view
our users as like Partners in bringing
this to fruition and putting this Tech
in front of more users more consumers
more businesses and so we're very
collaborative like we don't want to rock
pull anyone we don't want any surprises
so long as like our terms are met
we want to be a partner we want to help
you build we want to like support you in
the best way possible I think some of
this Paradox might be from a from a
legal point of view because I I agree
with you I you call it the playground
and that's a great term for it I I think
that some of the most exciting
applications of large language models
haven't been discovered yet and they'll
be discovered when you have a diverse
community of people kind of sharing and
trying interesting things but just from
that legal point of view um so we were
we were a bit worried actually that some
of the customers of our application
might send us up malicious prompts and
and have our service terminated and the
way that we've been thinking about
working around it on Open AI it's not
possible on kohio I don't think is kind
of getting the users to sign up for the
service directly and then just pasting
their key inside our application so that
you know they're responsible they're
getting themselves blocked if they do
anything bad and legally that puts us in
a much safer position but how do you
feel about that I mean that's a great
technique I think it should be supported
on code here if it's not already I think
it is we have a few people doing stuff
like that
um
like a bring your own key type
application
um alternatively a cohere would want to
work with you to help you moderate use
um to catch Bad actors to catch misuse
out of terms use Etc
um
so we'll be very collaborative we'll
help you do that we'll help you look at
the data it will help you find users who
are misusing it we won't just blanket
ban you
um because one of your users is trying
to like adversarily attack your business
right like we're we're trying to build
with you and so I think we'll be
quite reasonable assuming that you're
reasonable too and that you don't want
that type of activity on your product so
it's about like supporting startup
Founders helping them build their own
tools to catch this sort of stuff and
ban those users
um
it's like a collaborative building
approach as opposed to yeah you're just
a user either comply or get banned
um
I we're much more
I don't know present
um
engaged
that makes sense I mean you can
appreciate my fear that um in in a sense
startup Founders have lost their
autonomy because it's it costs millions
and millions of dollars uh you folks are
hiring some of the most talented people
in the world to do this stuff and we're
building on on top of that Foundation
which at the moment it seems like a risk
but I I appreciate that in spirit it
shouldn't it shouldn't actually be a
risk but um just talking high levels so
um how would you distinguish your
service from let's say gpt3
so I think the opening a team and gbt3
they did like a fantastic Thing by
opening that up and giving it to the
World
um
in terms of distinguishing ourselves
from them I think they've taken a very
hands-off approach to this stuff
um
and they put out endpoints and it's kind
of like a good luck have fun go build
um
with cohere we're trying to be more
present and engaged and we're trying to
tailor our roadmap
towards the needs of users so
um
for instance we're listening to users
and seeing what they're signing up for
what they're asking from us one of those
things is summarization
and so now we've spun up an effort to
release a summarization endpoint that's
generally useful across summarizing chat
transcripts like long documents that
type of thing
um and so it's a two-way street it's not
just that our users are the consumers of
our path towards whatever we want it's
like a dialogue in a conversation of
what do you need what should we build
next what do you see coming
um and then we go build it
so it's very much a
it feels more
two-way Community oriented we're trying
to build the right product for our users
and the most useful product possible and
so the way we do that is just through
dialogue and conversation and people
asking for the thing that they need they
want
open AI service suddenly kind of got a
lot better recently and I think they
call it DaVinci to it's a bit of a
mystery because I reviewed gbt3 when it
first came out a couple of years ago and
recently it seems much better and if I
understand correctly they've done some
kind of fine-tuning using reinforcement
learning to align it to human
preferences that instruct GPT or
something like that I don't even know if
that's the case but I just wondered if
you could comment on that and and do you
folks plan to do something similar
yeah so we we don't call them instruct
models we call them command models
because of the co and Co here
um but we do have something currently in
private beta uh hopefully we'll release
it soon
um but yeah it has a huge impact on
model performance like the ability to
specify an instruction specify an intent
describe the type of problem that you're
solving completely changes model
performance
um
and in some ways it's surprising in
other ways it's very not surprising in
that these models are just trained on
web scraped data you like there's no
reason why you would expect them to
behave the way that they do we're just
kind of lucky that they work as few shot
uh programs
um
and so I think this
aligning with humans intent human
commands human instructions
um
it's just a much more natural way to
interface with these models I think
before instruct style models
it was a bit like
you would have to discover the language
of the model right and it was like this
very opaque process of Shifting things
around rephrasing things trying to
figure out like
okay what makes sense to this model
super brittle super painful
um
this command style model actually pulls
that away and it's much more intuitive
it's much more fluid it's the way that
you would expect to interact with the
model
yeah it's really interesting how you
know when Steve Jobs released the iPad
he said there was something magic about
it something a magic about that
interface and similarly with these newer
models
um if it was like an invisible boundary
as being crossed where I I trust it in a
way it's a trap because I'm
anthropomorphizing it more because of
exactly what you just said before but
um I wanted to get into some engineering
characteristics of cohere so I'll send
you some quick fire questions so um how
many tokens in a context window so at
the moment it's 2048
um and it should flip the 4096 shortly
um but our goal is for an infinite token
with
um wow and so there's a few efforts that
we're pursuing to enable that
um yeah how many uh concurrent requests
can your customers have perky
infinite as many as you'd like
oh even now
yes yeah I think uh
there's a top level bottleneck which we
can actually remove for specific
customers who need more
um I think it's like
10 000 queries per minute
um
but we have folks doing
billions and billions of characters a
day and so
um
yeah we're happy to remove that
restriction for those applications that
need it do you support
um let's say Enterprise security
scenarios like single sign-on key
rotation that kind of thing
so we do we do SSO we don't do key
rotation yet we're hoping to build that
out
um like with other Enterprise
requirements like
um co-location and that sort of thing
we're also building out the capability
to do that on different clouds
um but at present we don't have that yet
but it's roadmapped
okay and you were just touching on this
before but what's the the kind of
largest most highly scaled application
deployed on cohere
so similar to I think what everyone's
been seeing the first sort of
application that has hit product Market
fit is copywriting
um
yeah there's a lot of companies Jasper
copy AI hyper right
um
they've really found something that
works for the average person drives tons
of value speeds people makes them more
efficient makes them more creative
um
and so that's where we're seeing volumes
just
Skyrocket
so I'm really excited about the
Prospectors stacking course to these
large language models so um building a
large computational graph of ref you
know repursive calls but doing all the
round trips at the moment is is pretty
slow it's almost like I want to create
this graph this computation graph I want
to ship it over to you you do it behind
the scenes on your app fabric with
parallelism you send me the results
because right now there's a significant
engineering challenge for me to do that
but I think that like you know the next
generation of application platforms will
be doing something like that there'll be
a fabric on top of cohere so are you are
you planning anything to kind of make my
life easier to do that
yeah
that's so cool I I hadn't actually
thought about that sorry no I haven't
actually thought about that
um
like basically compiling a graph uh of
chained prompts to cohere
and shipping it over
that's fascinating
I guess what you gain is the two-way
Network
um cost right like that's what you're
saving
um and network costs tend to be quite
small in practice
so depending on how big your prompt is
and how many tokens you're generating I
could see it
not giving you a huge amount of of lift
but
um
yeah I'd love to look at your use case
and kind of understand
um is the issue actually with the fact
that you're having to make multiple
Network requests in sequence or is it
that the underlying model itself is too
small and what you need is actually just
speed UPS to that core model
um
another thing that cohere does
is we'll do just like specific
deployments for customers so some folks
have very low latency requirements and
we can split up our model across more
nodes more more gpus
um and that makes the latency go way way
down
um so if you were looking for like a you
know 6X speed up a 4X speed up in
latency that's one easy way to do it
yeah I think we're only just scratching
the surface of what's possible here so
if I did this that I did you know what I
just spoke about I would need to create
a workflow engine I would need to do all
sorts of dag optimization and
parallelism and I might be able to Cache
certain steps and certain steps I might
be able to do some meta machine learning
to optimize the performance that needs
to go you know that needs a large one
that needs a small one there's there's a
whole kind of universe I think that we
can explore here you know just going one
one level of abstraction higher you know
because the next startup Founders will
be building platforms that essentially
compose human knowledge
on top of these large language models in
some kind of a fabric so I think I think
that that's that's what excites me at
the moment
that's really cool that's really cool
okay so you express this graph of like
prompts chaining into each other uh we
might have loops and conditions and
um
you compile that you ship it to the
large language model provider they
perform optimizations they handle all
the parallelism all the conditions
that's a really fascinating product idea
I like that yeah please build it so I
don't have to anyway
um I wanted to come on to some more llm
discussions so um our friend Francois
cholei he says that large language
models are a bit like databases right
um but to me they seem like so much more
than that right so I think Francois was
saying they are the representation you
know equivalent to the beach restructure
in a database but
um I think they're also the database
engine as well but it's a new type of
database engine we don't understand how
this database engine works it's kind of
unintelligible to us but do you think
that's a good analogy or like how do you
mentally kind of think about what's
going on in a language model
yeah I like the analogy I I like yours
a bit better I think my own
I kind of view
just a
raw large language model trained on the
web as the next iteration of a search
engine
um
instead of explicitly retrieving results
and references out into
the web so I like to use the analogy of
like search engines and instead of like
explicit hard references where you make
a query you get back a link out to some
site
um a language model it's kind of more
like a it's like a dialogue you can
extract information from it it has all
of this knowledge that it's seen
throughout the web it's like a soft
version of a search engine
um and the mode of Discovery is still
language it's just a much more
natural interface it's like a
conversation as opposed to
um
what we type into Google which is kind
of its own language right like we don't
query in the same way we would ask our
teacher our calc teacher about a theorem
um
we write in a very strange way I think
language models are much more natural
modality to
the Corpus of human knowledge it's much
more intuitive natural seamless
the problem is they hallucinate a lot
and so they'll fill in gaps they're
compressors right and so they see the
web and they try to compress that down
into their parameters and they they lose
little bits and pieces and then when
they have to regurgitate it reconstruct
it they'll just you know fill in a
plausible answer inside those gaps and
so the other reason I'm really excited
about retrieval models is that they
ground them more in reality you put less
burden on the model's parameters to
memorize every single fact that's out
there and you instead just have them do
the distillation process so the model
makes a query out to this this knowledge
base this this database of true facts it
pulls back some references and then the
model is just asked hey given these
references
you know answer my question and so it
can actually make reference to True
Facts instead of having to hallucinate
and imagine its own facts
um
so yeah my my kind of like
the analogy that I like to build off of
is this is the next search engine it's
the next interface to the Internet it's
the next interface to human knowledge
it's funny you say that it might
actually be the next search engine soon
I think search engines are about to be
revolutionized but
um yeah I was going to ask you about the
next Frontier of large language models
and we've already been speaking about
some of it so you're talking about the
integration of information retrieval
which will ground the the responses you
know based on actual things which exist
in your operational systems we just
spoke before about a hierarchical
compositions having this exciting uh you
know computational graph uh maybe some
different architecture types or
interaction patterns as well I mean if
you were just saying that there's this
back and forth interaction which I think
is really interesting on Google at the
moment you just type in a search and you
press search once you're not iteratively
refining reflexively recursively
multimodality was another thing I
thought of you know maybe having
language in and text out but um I mean
those are a few examples but does
anything come top of mind to you for the
the next the next front
yeah like in addition to what you just
listed I think
the ability to keep State over a
long-term Horizon like my dream for
cohere
is that it knows its users
it can see into the past of all the past
interactions with each one of these
users it knows their preferences it
knows it knows about the user and the
way that they like to interact with this
model and to do that it can't be
transactional it can't just be like
um
text in text out you know forget
everything else
um
in the history we need to be able to
like maintain a state between the model
and its user we need to be able to keep
a record of that uh I was talking about
with retro the ability to add into that
Corpus keep notes uh kind of like
maintain an internal dialogue we've seen
how useful that is with like the scratch
Pad
um techniques that people have been
working on
um just giving the model space to write
out its thoughts before giving an answer
I think we need the ability to store
that forever and to have that
referenceable down the line in the
future
so yeah I think that's one of the most
exciting ones and then of course there's
multimodality which is
blowing up now
um again it's like another form of
grounding it ties the model into the
real world into the physical reality
of our world
um
I think that's super exciting so yeah I
think the ability to reference external
knowledge bases contribute to its own
knowledge base the ability to understand
the world not just through text but
through audio video images and then
lastly
augmenting large language models with
the ability to use tools
obviously like we built this world
for ourselves and we built all these
little things to integrate with us and
one of our primary modalities is
language and so a lot of our tools are
language driven
um
if you think about web web browsing it's
mostly you reading text and clicking
links and following and it's very text
driven
and so something I'm super excited about
is
okay well we have these language models
which have pretty good grasp of language
they seem to have you know some modest
level of understanding can we actually
get them to use the tools that we built
for us us humans stuff like web browsers
um and the results we're seeing there
are just super exciting super exciting
cool um I wanted to ask you about
different modes of understanding
um I'm actually making a video at the
moment on the Chinese Rim argument but
um you know they say that shortcut
learning is an often discussed
characteristic of machine learning right
so when a system achieves human light
performance on a benchmark by the
sleight of hand if you like of spurious
correlations in the data rather than
what we inhibit we ensue it to be
human-like comprehension now um large
language models have learned this very
intricate statistical correlation right
which allows near perfect performance in
in lieu of human cognition and it's
possible that evaluating these
algorithms against standards designed to
gauge human cognition might be barking
up the wrong tree now human
comprehension is difficult to pin down
exactly what it means but it doesn't
seem to be entirely reflected in large
language models not always in how they
behave at least now for humans
it's not always enough to know the
statistical features of linguistic
symbols we also need to grasp the
underlying ideas and contexts in which
those symbols convey while language
models can pick up on these tiny
statistical patterns that we never could
Melanie Mitchell said in her most recent
paper that recent years in AI have
produced machines with new modes of
knowledge so in the same way that
various animals are better suited to
different settings so too will our
intelligent systems be you know more
adapted to various issues she said that
large-scale statistical models will
continue to be favored for matters
requiring these vast amounts of
historically encoded knowledge and where
performance is Paramount and human
intelligence intelligence might be
favored for problems where we have very
limited knowledge and we have strong
causal mechanisms so you know my
question to you basically is what is the
difference between a machine learning
algorithm which has learned these very
intricate statistical correlations and a
human which has developed a more
lifelike comprehension
I think that the first and shortest
answer is probably the objective
function right like the context that we
evolved in is very very different than
the context that we're training these
models in
um
certainly like humans have a model of
language
we're doing language modeling for sure
but we have to do a lot on top of that
and that's just one component that we
rely on in order to achieve our
objective and go through life and
procreate
um
I think for these language models
they're given just that one piece of it
and there's a lot within that one piece
just within language modeling like
you're forced to learn I mean a ton of
facts you're forced to learn a ton of
patterns
um
and so it is quite extraordinary that
all of this amazing Behavior falls out
of just the language modeling problem
um
but it's also not right because in order
to accurately model language in a
generalizable way you're forced to pick
up stuff like how do I translate how do
I classify stuff because that's
represented
in the data but when you're asking
questions about
you know how come language models get
this thing wrong which humans find super
intuitive or it's so obvious so logical
the contexts are completely different
right like we didn't evolve to just be a
language model I think that anyone who's
claiming that
um has a high burden of proof
um
and it also points back to
like what we were saying earlier around
is this the last architecture is it just
this plus scale
there's more that needs to be there and
also in the objective function right
like we can't just do
language modeling all the way I think
language modeling will get us very far
and I think that we can take language
models and augment them with these very
useful additional components we can give
them access to tools
um
but fundamentally
if you're looking for something that's
human-like and
um acts and behaves like us like there's
an objective function change that needs
to happen
um it can't just be language modeling
there needs to be something more yeah we
all learn anthropomorphize AI to
different degrees I think but I mean
what I took from Melanie is that she
thinks that language models are not
anthropomorphic that is a completely
different mode but do you think that
humans do think like language models and
we have some other apparatus on the top
or or do you kind of agree with Melanie
that they're completely different I
don't think they're completely different
I don't think they're like
I I would not agree that they're
categorically different
I think they're categorically our brains
and modeling and statistical models I I
think that they overlap
very very heavily
um
again I think the objective function is
just completely different
I'm a big believer that the real value
of AI models exists as a kind of
entangled form of interactive creative
pairing between a human brain and a
model so David Chalmers coined the term
extended Minds to talk about us and
phones and I think actually large
language models that's the real extended
mind because I I feel this when I play
with large language models I feel that
it's truly intelligent in combination or
in tandem with me so um you know large
language models I don't have agency or
intentionality but we do and we can use
them and something very interesting
emerges from that as an example and I
mean I want to build a virtual assistant
that comes with me everywhere it's part
of my everyday experience and I'm just
in tandem with a large language model
producing all sorts of you know creative
thoughts that that are kind of embodied
in the environment I'm in that I think
is an extension of my intelligence
yeah yeah I I 100 agree
um I'm thinking about like
what happened with search and the
Outsourcing of knowledge
um
not even that long ago like a pre-google
right
we had to memorize a lot of stuff it had
to be digested
um some stuff we could Outsource into
books and that type of thing and we
would retrieve them very slowly and very
painfully as needed
um
and then came the search engine and
mobile phones and at any moment any
piece of information that you need you
have a source to to go get it
um
and so we took that taxing
taxing on our neurons taxing on our time
activity of having to pull a book off
the shelf and we turned it into like an
instantaneous thing and so that freed up
our minds freed up our time
to do a lot more high impact
activities and we've been significantly
more productive as a product
um
I think the next step is to continue to
Outsource things that we don't like
doing
things that are taxing they're time
consuming
um that we put off that we don't like to
hand more of that work over to the
language model over to these
ml systems AI systems
um and to free ourselves up to just
focus on the things that humans care
about that we enjoy
um the things that we're best at
so I think it's another complete
transformation it just turns out that
you can hand way way more than just the
knowledge over to a language model you
can hand entire activities
um
yeah that's what I'm excited about I
like your your idea of like a personal
assistant coming around with you you can
give it an instructor oh yeah I need to
buy
body wash and it shows up at your door
tomorrow I'm building instead of me
having it you're building it oh so the
topic topic for another day
um quick quick five question
um you know we spoke about language
being the the next interface for
application development right so um you
know I'm really excited about this
possible future I'm already building it
but there's also a bit of a Panacea
element to it because you know the cell
the cells pitch is that even my
community you know my users could become
software developers they could actually
build my platform my platform becomes
kind of like um amorphous because it's
it's so it's so distributed but the
worry is that we'll get into this
situation where we might feel we need to
reinvent code because the the prompts
might become so complex that you need
the equivalent of lawyers to understand
them um do you think about that concern
I um
I have not because coher's whole point
is to abstract that away and to try and
make things as simple to use as possible
and to come up with
you know canonical standards
um abstractions even above prompting
that are easier to use so that it pushes
out further it becomes less of a dark
art or
um
becomes less complex
I think in order for this stuff to
proliferate that's like a necessary
condition things have to get easier it
can't be like you're speaking to an
alien
um or you're having to Divine a prompt
that happens to work
um
so I yeah I think that's where the arrow
of progress in this field points is
towards more abstraction easier to use
more intuitive interfaces so I'm not too
concerned about that because that's
something that's very much top of mind
I think Gomez it's been an absolute
honor thank you for joining us likewise
likewise thank you so much Tim